Wednesday 11th of June, an annoy 2025,
Ben Hanwell here at the helm on Steve
Bond's war room. Welcome uh folks.
Thanks for for tuning in. Uh we're going
to carry on something that we launched
last week and the our two guests u who
were here last week, Frank Walker and
Jenny Holland. there sitting by waiting
to come in later as we chew over the
week's most important developments in
the the whole arena of Christianity in
the fight for the Christian faith uh in
the public square. But my first guest
today, Raymond Ibrahim, uh Raymond,
thanks for coming on the show. I first
saw your writings in your analysis some
15 or so years ago and I've been
following you since then. you you had
some great contributions to make um on
Jihad Watch, which is a great website
run by uh Robert Spencer. Um but in in
the intervening years, I know you've
produced a number of a number of books.
We're going to talk about your third one
in in in your trilogy right now, but
you've also um you put out stuff with
the Gatesstone Institute, which I also
subscribed to, by the way. You've been
involved with the Middle East Forum and
uh I think you've been a visiting fellow
at the Hoover Institute. So you've got a
a whole cycle of experience under your
belt. Tell us a bit though about your
new book which is the two swords of
Christ. Um I know this is the third one
in your series and and the first two
books have had huge resonance uh in our
sector in our segment here. Um tell us
before you tell us about what the book's
about, tell us what it what uh inspired
you to write it because I think in all
three of these books there are messages
to our contemporary time.
Yeah. Uh, good to be with you, Ben.
Excuse me. Uh, well, it's hard to talk
about that book without talking about
the its predecessors, the other two, and
because they all have a sort of
synergistic, um, you know, effect on one
another. They complement one another. Um
so just to briefly summarize the first
book sort and scimitar subtitle 14
centuries of war between Islam and the
west really traces the the uh history of
conflict between Islam and the west
which of course is its modern term uh
historically was christendom and I I
start really from the beginning with the
first uh you know couple of years after
Muhammad's lifetime uh with the first
battle in 636 and we fast forward all
the way until America's first war as a
nation the Barbary wars with Muslims and
I highlight you know the decisive
battles
uh and how they really had a tremendous
impact on the shaping of the world that
very few people you know know. Um
there's a a European older European
historian his name is Franco Cardini and
he said very memorably that Islam was a
violent midwife to Europe because so
much of what Europe really became was a
byproduct of continuous uh aggression
from surrounding Islam. And we and the
book also shows sword and scimitar that
you know a lot of the countries or
nations or regions that we think or a
lot of people think today are have
always been Muslim. The Muslim world
especially the Arab world all of that
was actually the was not just Christian
it was actually the greater part of
Christendom. And so Islam uh I I show in
that book in the first few chapters how
Islam just completely in one century
conquered all that region from Egypt and
greater Syria, the Middle East all the
way to Morocco and then even got into
Spain. Um so a lot of people are not
aware that so much of what was once
Christendom about 66 or 70% if you look
at a map was actually permanently
swallowed up by Islam and and later by
the Turks Asia Minor what we call Turkey
today was one of the oldest you know
Christian regions. um epistles are in
there. Book of Revelation talks about
its cities. Um so anyway, that's uh
that's sort of scimitar defenders of the
west um was sort of similar but it was
more a biographies. I chose eight
biographies of eight men who I I
identify as defenders of Christendom
vavv Islam and uh it also moves
chronologically
and that I know I know a lot of people
find that very inspiring and that's
partially why I also wanted to write it.
It's sort of a it's the same it's the
same theme but now I'm really like
zooming in on the lives of specific men
kings and warriors and emperors who you
know took the cause and the newest book
now uh the two swords of Christ is uh I
originally conceived it as a book about
the military orders and uh but
eventually it just became about the two
primary ones really who spearheaded the
defense of Christendom uh which would be
the knights of the temple and the
knights of the hospital or the templars
and hospitalers uh respectively.
And that I think uh you know the
relevance of that book well what it is
is just it's a history again it's a
history of those how they came into
being how the military orders came into
being the the rationale behind them and
I think that's very important and in
fact that's the title of the book two
swords of Christ is a reference uh to
the passage in Luke where Christ says
you know sell your garment and buy a
sword and um his disciples say look Lord
here are two swords and he says that is
enough now even though that verse has
been allegorized to absolute
meaninglessness today. Um, it actually
meant something to premodern and
especially medieval Christians. And what
it meant is you there's two sorts of
evil and you have two kinds of swords to
fight against them. You have a secular
sword against physical evil and you have
a spiritual sword against um spiritual
evil. So modern day Christians only
believe in the latter one apparently and
they've completely lost focus on the on
the former which is a physical sword. Um
so we get into the theology of how they
came to be how they came to rise to
power and you find it amazing again
today in our modern Christian western
climate to be a Christian is you know to
be passive and to be tolerant and you
know uh to be a doormat in many ways but
these guys who were essentially monks
and really lived very pious uh lives
were also very violent men and so you
know reconciling the twain seems to be
odd and I I think it's very fascinating
when you understand the sort of
theological um understanding that they
had uh you know and another thing that
medieval Christians did that modern day
you know we go ahead. So sorry Raymond I
I want to go into this um because we
have a few minutes to break this down in
a in a few more in a bit more detail as
we go on in the show. First of all, I
want to ask you, is it your thesis then
that from when Muhammad first appeared
in the um in the in the sixth century,
right? Um in the um the late uh the late
late fifth century, seventh century um
sixth century. Is it is it your thesis
that there has basically been a
continuous
physical battle and you can you can also
argue a spiritual battle visav
Christianity and Islam all throughout
this period and that battle is still
taking place in the present day or is it
your thesis that that talking about the
Knights Templar and the Knights Hospital
these things are really um these these
are historically battles that belonged
in the past.
No, it's the former. It's it's it's a
continuous war. Um, so historically,
again, Sword and Scimitar is the book
that does this. It historically shows
you that the war was non-stop. Of
course, I mean, when we're talking 14
centuries, there's there's going to be
times of peace because of whatever
reason, and there's truses, etc., etc.,
But the general hostility was constant
an overall remember in the by you know
Islam Muhammad is 7th century dies at
632 and in the 16th century in the 1500s
you have Muslims going to Iceland and
Denmark to raid and England to raid
slaves under the same exact logic that
the Quran tells us it's you're an
infidel a keer etc. However having said
that what I would contend is that what's
happening is the same hostility has gone
on except it's taken different
manifestations and different guises. Um
and it's it it's it's continuous the
continuum from the Muslim side is
unwavering. The problem is the
discontinuity of the west. In other
words, and this is why it's good and uh
timely to read about men like this these
knights and how they perceived this war
which was both physical and spiritual in
their mind. Hence the two swords. Um but
now you know it it's taking forms. Islam
is so weak and uh you know the forebears
of Europe and western you know the
western Christians would be turning in
their graves to see that finally you
know the west is supreme more powerful
technologically economically tech you
know militarily and it's still suffering
worse than uh when you keep in mind
during these centuries of the long war
between Islam and the west Europe was
the underdog that was the weak one that
was the one who was being battered and
was like really until you know maybe
17th century and so forth or 16th centur
country. Um, so now though you got the
same hostility. So let's say Europe
brings in all these uh, you know, the
demographic change and they're bringing
t millions of migrants from the Muslim
world and lo and behold, they're doing
the same sorts of things that they did
when they used to invade Europe with the
sword, but now they're being welcomed
in. So, you know, it's the same kind of
thing that's going on. Churches all
throughout Europe and in Western
countries are constantly being attacked
and desecrated. Crosses are being
broken. And so to me it's a pattern of
unwavering hostility that goes all the
way back to the 7th century. But because
the west has kind of distanced itself
from its own heritage and you know
broken away from Christendom and that
idea um it's it doesn't see it. It
doesn't understand it. It's working
under this guise of multiculturalism and
you know any problem that goes on it has
to do with you know economics uh or
grievances. And so they don't understand
the sort of existential hostility that
has been just unwavering and well doc as
I document in my books. It's not hasn't
stopped and it's still going on. What
about this thesis that you'll find
pretty much in most of the media and
modern academia that here were these
peaceable Muslims just getting on with
their life and you have the brutality of
of Christians and the crusades going in
and and for no reason whatsoever
attacking um because you know the
Christians are the bad guys, the Muslims
are the good guys. that that's basically
the the the the modern perception, the
narrative that you'll pick up here in
the West. What's your um what's your
reading on that? And is your book in
some ways a corrective to that um that
alternative history, that fake history?
Exactly. In regards to the latter point,
exactly the reason I wrote these books,
this trilogy essentially is as a
corrective to that narrative. And you're
also right, that is the predominant
narrative. It's uh what I call fake
history. And as I often say, fake
history is much more dangerous than fake
news because it creates overarching
narratives and paradigms that people
sift current events through. Um, so if
you believe what you just said, not you,
but people in general, and they do, that
you know, medieval Christians and
crusaders were the aggressors, Muslims
were peaceful, tolerant victims. Um, if
you believe that, of course, then you
fast forward and you look at events
today. And I mean, you know, a few years
ago, I think like thousands of Germans
did a march to the Holy Land wearing uh
shirts with Arabic. It said, "I'm sorry
for the Crusades." Okay. So, it puts you
in this position where you feel like you
have to make uh concessions because
you're the bad guy. Let's make up for
what our ancestors did. Let's not let's
now like turn a new leaf and let's give
Muslims the benefit of the doubt, etc.,
etc. But if you actually um you know and
and it's so diabolical the way that this
fake history because I've really read a
lot of books written by secondary
historians who are supposed to be well
renowned and the things they say it's
just you know I'll give you one example
of you know well-known u professor John
Espazito from Georgetown University
which is where I attended for a while
and um you know he's the editor-inchief
of Oxford books on Islam and he's
written so many books published by the
Oxford University Press and he literally
says says in one in one of his books, I
think it's called Islam the straight
path. He says five centuries of peaceful
coexistence between Muslims and
Christians elapsed before an imperial
papal power play led to series of
so-called holy wars that have left an
enduring legacy of mistrust. In other
words, as Muslims and Christians just
got along hunky dory for five centuries
until the first crusade in 1095 when
these evil imperialistic uh you know po
papal power play popes and Catholics
decided to go and attack innocent
Muslims. The reality as I sort of
alluded earlier is the complete
opposite. In those five centuries Islam
destroyed and wreaked havoc all
throughout Christrysendom. In one year
alone, according to a Muslim historian,
in the year 109, the the the khalif the
fatib khalif in Egypt, Hakimah,
according to Muslim historian al-
Makrizi, destroyed 30,000 churches in
greater Syria in Egypt, including the
holy sele which he raised to the ground.
So, and this is this is during the five
centuries of peaceful coexistence. Um,
so even leading up to the first crusade,
the mass havoc and the massacres that
the Turks were causing in Asia Minor and
attacks and rapes on nuns who were going
on pilgrimage. That's exactly what the
Christians spoke about at Claremont at
the council of Clmont with Pope Urban
II. It was that it was to redress and um
defend Christendom from what was
happening. But that has been so expuned
today. And you know it starts off like I
just told you with that quote. Um and
the same page that John Espazito where
he says five centuries a piece you know
he also says he mockingly dismisses the
fact that when the crusaders say said
deos vult God will ws it. He writes,
"Yeah, the God may have willed it, but
there's no evidence that the Christians
in the Holy Land willed it." Well, all
contrare and and as I showed in a recent
article and video, um there's copious
evidence of Middle Eastern Christians,
Syriak, Armenian, who when the crusaders
came, they just threw themselves and
kissed their feet because they helped,
you know, alleviate what was happening
to them, which was mass persecution um
by Muslims. So yeah, this this is a very
a potent fake history that's meant to
demonize Christians and demonize
especially medieval Christianity. I
think there is a force out there that is
very scared that Western Christian men
might start sort of gravitating and find
appealing medieval Christian men
specifically the two nights uh the two
night groups that I spoke about in the
two swords of Christ the knights of the
temple and hospital.
Tell me something Raymond. What do you
think about the um the Catholic Church
in the decades following the second
Vatican Council? Has it had a role to
play in trying to
present the the truth behind the defense
of Christians in the Middle East under
Islamic conquest? or has it uh has it do
you think rather somewhat sold the past
behind a deceptively
um uh
dialoguebased
interaction um with Islam? Could it have
done more? Um, and are you looking
towards the new pope, Pope um, Leo the
14th to change the the position um,
somewhat from the position of of Pope
Francis and his and his numerous
declarations like I think it was Abu
Dhabi um, um, his declaration with
regards to Islam. Um, so there's two two
questions there. Do do you think the
Catholic Church has done enough um in
presenting to Catholics the truth about
uh the the the Islamic conquest of
Christendom in the previous centuries?
And are you looking and hoping for a
change under the new pope?
Yeah, as far as the first question, no,
it has not done enough, especially under
Pope Francis. um you know he he was much
more it seems interested in just
dialogue and and and trying to show you
know some fraternal peaceful overtures
towards the Islamic world and he did a
lot of these meetings with the um with
the grandm of Egypt Sheikh Ahmed Alibab
and it's just you know as as a person
like me who who watches and reads in
Arabic and I I I get to watch the so I I
would watch Pope Francis and the talking
and hugging each other and kissing each
other and talking about peace and love
and how Muslims and Christians are, you
know, brother religions and should help
each other. And then I would watch the
shikh speaking in Arabic saying the
exact opposite and not sounding not
unlike ISIS, you know, when it comes to
the Christian is the cafeter, the
infidel, we can't have churches and and
all the all that sort of thing. But of
course, he he doesn't he doesn't speak
it the way ISIS does. He tries to be a
little more diplomatic, but it's the
same mentality. And al which is you know
almost like the equ equivalent of the
Vatican people will say of of the
Islamic world is is notorious for
publishing books that what we would call
radical Islam and they have no choice
because those are the books of Islam the
hadith and the you know the s the
biography of Muhammad and all the
special studies. So, it's a one-sided
thing. And, you know, and a lot of the
Muslims and when Christians from the
Middle East watch this, they just they
can't believe it because he's being so
hoodwinkedked. Uh, Pope Francis, unless
of course he knew that and uh it doesn't
matter because he just wants to put a
show of, hey, we're signing all these
Excuse me. Let me just stop you there.
What's your reading of the situation?
Because no one follows these things more
attentively than you. Do you think he
was acting do you think Burggali was
acting in good faith or do you think he
was actually acting um in bad faith with
his presentation
to Catholics that Islam is a peaceful
religion?
You know the only way to answer that
question is you know how what's his
intelligence level? You know does he did
he really believe what he was saying or
you know is he that naive um or does or
was this wishful thinking or is this
just like I said kind of a show. I think
it's a little bit of all. You know, it's
a combination. He's hoping, but he also
knows probably not, especially when
people like me would expose what, you
know, his counterpart would say and do
soon thereafter uh after these meetings.
Um but as far as uh you know and he
would for example write encyclicals
about the environment but it's like you
could have written an encyclical about
the fact that something like uh I think
the latest estimate published by um the
human rights group open doors on their
world watch list is I don't know like
400 million Christians around the world
are being persecuted and some of them
really graphically in in Nigeria you
have two Christians being killed uh
every hour okay for their faith. So you
would think as the pope and here's the
irony when you go back and you study the
history and as I show in these books the
the men who spearheaded the crusades
were the popes. These were the guys who
were the most um you know stalwart
resistors against Islamic violence and
the spread of Islam. And so it's funny
now when you fast forward to a Pope
Francis and they come off you know so
wishy-washy. Um, as far as the new pope,
uh, you know, I think one can have some
hope, but in the end, I just feel
swollen legs aren't the problem. They
might be edema symptoms. What looks like
just puffy, tired legs might be
something deeper. Edema happens when the
body's drainage system, the lymph, slows
down, and when it does, fluid has
nowhere to go. You can prop your legs
up, cut the salt, walk more. If the
system underneath isn't moving, the
swelling stays. Edema isn't just about
what you see. It's about what's
happening under the surface. And your
body wants you to notice. You don't need
extreme solutions. There are natural
ways to support that system. Start by
understanding how it really works. Watch
the video below. Know what your body's
actually telling you. All it takes is
one click on the link below.
[Music]
these these institutions are just being
such big vast institutions they can't
help but have to be diplomatic. Um so
there's probably only so much he will
say or do though I think he understands
the situation better. He's already
talked about um you know I I don't
remember the exact details but he's
you've already referenced that
Christians are being persecuted so
that's a good sign. Um and we just need
It would be nice for popes to go back to
how they used to be in a way when they
were the chief defenders of the faith.
It it would indeed be nice to go back to
the way things used to be when popes
were were Catholic. Um, look, we've got
a break coming up in in 5 minutes. There
is a story that I did wanted to quickly
hit with you, but I think we'll hold it
over now until after the the the break.
One thing I did want to ask you um
however listening to you talk is that u
it's conscious to me that um
that guys men males if you will um are
having a moment you've got this whole
thing um in social media about the
manosphere and as I was sort of
listening to you talking about this
muscular form of Christianity uh that we
saw in the past and I know you elsewhere
you've described templars and um andos
hospitalist as not as soldiers and not
as cloistered monks but both together at
the same time. Given that chaps
um have really had a backseat in the
Catholic Church following the um the
second Vatican council um and there is a
moment taking place now within this
wider manos manos manosphere uh concept.
Just tell me something about your
reading of the situation. Is there
anything that is going that you know in
in the books these three books but
specifically um the two swords of Christ
that speaks to this this contemporary
dynamic specifically about men leading
up and taking leadership roles um within
the church once again.
Yeah, I think that's one of the key
points that comes out in this history.
Uh the the two swords of Christ about
the knights um is again it's this fusion
of piety and militancy which is so alien
uh you know to your modern day Christian
who has just been bred into becoming a
doormat. um you know they've taken
the whole idea you know this turn the
other cheek has been so I think
weaponized um by people who actually
hate Christianity and at the same time I
often wonder to myself you know are
people too are people men especially are
they overly fond of boasting that
they're turning the other cheek because
Jesus commanded them to or is the first
premise that they're really cowards and
they're f they found the pious pretext
to hide behind which is you know I don't
want to be confrontational I don't want
to be judgmental I don't want to do
anything and oh yeah cuz Jesus told me
to. Um I'm starting to think that's
really what's going on. Um and that
they've been bred to become so passive,
so cowardly. Um a lot of men in the west
and obviously I'm generalizing and a lot
of men are not like that in the west
obviously. Um but I think it's been
weaponized uh this passive side of if
you go back in premodern time you know
even though it seems so taken for
granted today that Christianity is
passive and peaceful and does nothing.
No one thought that way you know. So
this is a new idea that was really been
uh it's a classic heresy, right? A
heresy is you take one aspect of
religion and you you know blow it out of
proportion and ignore all the rest.
Where's the aspect of you know uh
overturning tables and a whip of cords
and driving people out due to righteous
indignation? You know where where do you
get that? Um it's missing. And uh it
wasn't missing for preodern men for
medieval men. It was very much there was
no conflict whatsoever between loving
your neighbor and fighting and defending
them and killing. You know, when you
think about it, both the knights of the
temple and the knights of the hospital,
they began in their origin of just
wanting to help their fellow man. They
were working on the verse, you know,
loving your fellow man as you love
yourself and loving God. That was that's
what led to the crusades. So the
Templars because when Christians would
go on uh pilgrimages after the first
crusade and now Jerusalem's under
crusader control um they were still
being killed and attacked by Muslims. So
in their in their origin the Templars
were just basically a vanguard to
protect pilgrims. And then the
hospitalers is even more telling because
these were actually the men who were
like a a care worker. You know, they
would people who would come and it was a
hospice and they would care for them and
they would wash them and feed them and
clothe them and you know and these are
the guys who became militant and violent
because to them in the end it was why
why am I going to sit in the hospital
and wait until you get attacked by
Muslims and then try to resuscitate you?
Why don't I actually go and pre uh
prevent it preemptive strike by
protecting you? Um, so it's amazing that
but for us today and this is why you
don't hear about these knights and the
Templars have been so demonized and
they've been turned into something that
doesn't even exist to pure mythology.
And I think it's because if you really
study them, they are appealing to
Christian masculinity and that's why
there's a concerted effort to keep them
suppressed or to demonize them or to
turn them into all the nonsense that
they've been turned into. Yeah. Which um
which ironically isn't a problem that
exists within the Islamic world. Um, far
from it. Uh, you know, ironically, it's
interesting that what you mentioned, and
I hadn't considered that before, that um
that basically the beta male mentality
can hide behind the precepts of our Lord
and and present themselves as sort of a
credential form of interior spirituality
when in fact it's just playing up in
your face cowardice. Right. Yep. It's
they're making a virtue out of a vice,
okay? It's it's cowardice and they hide
behind uh because think about it, you
know, non-confrontationalism,
non-judgmentalism, non, you know, being
tolerant of everything. Well, that's the
easy route. That's the easy thing to do
because you never get in anyone's face.
You never resist. Um, you know, so I
think a lot of people have adopted that
and that's that comes first. That's the
first premise. And then the the you
know, the second premise is what Jesus
said. So it's being it's instead of what
it should be is that you want to do
right and you know if someone strikes
you you want to actually kill them but
you don't you control yourself that's
how it should be all right and that's
what Jesus I believe was and keep in
mind you know everyone this turn the
other cheek business the one verse Jesus
get actually gets slapped in the gospels
he didn't turn his other cheek he
actually challenged the man um so
clearly this is a very symbolic thing to
say and it should never in any way shape
or form be actually practiced And no one
did because they had just warned. We
heard from Frank Walker about the the
procession, the pilgrimage in shot,
which was actually which was the you saw
the bishops there trying to stamp down
on the very thing that that that that
young people are thirsting for. You
heard what Jenny Holland was just saying
who's not a she's not a she's not a
Catholic, not not a believer, but she's
saying the same thing again and again of
the of people searching for the sacred,
for the transcendent. How do you tie
this in all all all these themes that
we've been discussing about on the show?
Tell me about this article in the
Washington Post specifically about the
numbers uh and and how things are going
and obviously with the narrative of what
you're talking about of this uh 1,500
1,600 uh year battle visa via
Christianity and Islam. What are the
numbers like? What are the dynamics
taking place in the in the West today?
in the world today.
Yeah. So, um as I had indicated, you
know, the the the jihad and the crusade
which went on for centuries until
recently. The jihad continues, but there
is of course absolutely no crusade. Um
what's uh it's it's taken different
guises and one of them of course is this
demographic jihad. They actually call
that it's called that um remember the
word jihad people apologists will tell
you it doesn't mean holy war. It means
struggle, strive. It does. And that
makes it even more dangerous because
historically the only way you were going
to struggle and strive against
Christians was through force because
they weren't going to give up or give,
you know, betray their heritage and
their faith just for fun. Um, like they
are today. But it also meant strive in
different ways. You can you strive with
your money. You can fund the jihad.
Strive by propaganda or lying. Then
there's the baby jihad, which is they
actually encourage Muslims, men and
women, to keep procreating uh children.
And you go now into Europe and almost
every large western city, Oslo, um
there's so many of them. I I already I
wrote about them, maybe four or five
capitals. And um the number one name is
of newborn baby boys is Muhammad. And uh
you know, there's a reason for that. The
parents are making a point, okay, that
they're choosing that name of all names.
It's not just any Arabic name. So uh
there's definitely a the just the
numbers are growing. And that's why when
you look at certain areas in Europe like
in Sweden or in the UK um Germany of
course France you have what you're
seeing which is uh a lot of these
Muslims are growing in numbers and uh
Europeans are not replacing themselves
as we know there's a decline in the
birth rate and if you look at certain
polls I remember a pew one I think it
says in Germany something like by 2050
Muslims are going to be I don't know
maybe like 40%. And I mean it's over
game over at that point if 20%'s even
enough. uh especially if you go back to
the idea of all these cowardly people
who think you know are making a virtue
of a vice by not resisting and not doing
anything 20% is plenty. So yeah, the
jihad continues un you know unabated and
it's taken different forms and now one
of them the main one is this sort of
baby demographic explosion and at the
same time as that report indicates you
know Christianity is seeing a sort of
withdrawal and I think a lot of that is
because modern-day western Christianity
is just not appealing it's just it's be
it's become such an abstract idea you
know it's been stripped of everything
stripped of all sort of concrete uh you
know a ritual is one aspect But even
more than ritual, it's stripped of
history. Um, and it's just an idea, you
know, oh, John 3:16, that's it. And now
I live my life like a secular person.
So, no wonder churches are, you know,
declining and and falling away because
we need a more robust historic form of
uh Christianity. That is what appealed
to people. That's what men fought and
died for as in in in those books, the
two swords of Christ. Um, and they're
not going to do it for, you know, what
what's being what's now being paraded as
Christianity, which is which is, as I
said, um, just a mask for craven
behavior essentially. Um, yeah, it this
is something that we've said, um, on the
show time and time again, that coherence
in religion is extremely compelling and
that's true whatever the religion is,
right? And this is one of the reasons
that we h we find today this curious
phenomenon that a false religion is in a
far stronger numerically arithmetically
in terms of momentum. You mentioned I
think the word uh demographic jihad a
false religion and in a far stronger
position than the true faith. Let me
just quote this thing here because I
have the figures right in front of me
from and this is the Washington Post.
Um, it says that Christianity's share of
world population decreased by 1.8
percentage points to 28.8%.
Um, and it says here, this is the I'm
quoting the Washington Post, the falloff
is driven in large part by
disaffiliation.
Um, I think Frank War and I, we could
spend a whole hour talking over exactly
what that means. Um, is the Muslim
population on the other hand increased
by 1.8 8 percentage points to 25.6.
Um, okay. So, I think that's really all
we have time for. Raymond Ibraim, very
very honored and grateful for you to
come on the show today. Just very
briefly, where do people go to get not
only the two swords of uh Christ, but
the the previous two books as well in
the trilogy?
Yeah, thanks Ben. Uh, you can you can
order in a lot of places online, but
easiest place probably is Amazon.
They're all available. um Sword and
Simitar Defenders of We the new book is
actually not published yet, but you can
pre-order it. Um and uh and like I said,
um but if you and they all stand alone,
you know, you don't have to read them to
understand them, but they do complement
each other because they're kind of
different uh lens on different kind of
aspects of the Crusades and these long
wars uh with Islam. But yeah, Amazon,
you can probably order all of them right
now. And on X.
Yeah. Yeah. Uh, I'm on X. Uh, and I also
started a new YouTube channel. I invite
everyone uh to to check it out. It's
called the Holy War channel where I
discuss all these topics um and more.
So, that's that's fun, too.
What's What's your handle on X? Where do
people go?
Uh Ray Yeah, actually the best place
just go to my website, raymondbrae.com.
Okay. And everything's there. You'll
find links to my ex uh links to my
Facebook even though I'm shadowbanned
there. So, even if you follow me there,
but uh and also to the YouTube stuff as
well as links to the books on Amazon.
Raven Ibrahim, thank you very much for
coming on the show.